it's not a pyramid scheme it is a it's
not even a scheme per se it's
I have to go make a call
this just
stinks don't touch it please don't touch
it
bye bye Miss chair model lady
I dreamed that we were married and you
treated me nice
is
[Music]
Brittany [__]
it's raining from the ceilings
like a
like
that copy okay
Ryan started the fire it was always
burning since the world returning Ryan
started the fire it was always fun it's
everybody
and I feel God in this Chili's tonight
I burned my foot very badly on my
Foreman grill and I now need someone to
come and bring me into work Ryan is uh
Dead goodbye
I don't know what that was
oh my God it is your birthday period
Stephen a fact Mandy and Dwight are
rocking the sales team I feel very
blessed
[Music]
oh
my God Michael open your mouth move
myself
aha we're making love Islands in the
Stream that is what we are no one in
between so tell me what do you want to
be when you grow up I want to be married
and have a hundred kids so I can have a
hundred friends and no one can say no to
being my friend
little kid lover that way people will
know exactly where my priorities are at
whenever you come into the office I want
you to think about this
we don't need to
yes we do what
oh
I did it
thank you
you don't even know my real name I'm the
Lizard King I am about to do something
very bold to this job that I've never
done before
try
thank you
I wonder what people like about me
probably my jugs this is a business
scenario right
I am a victim of a hate crime
Stanley knows what I'm talking about
that's not what a hate crime is well I
hated it a lot okay I hey
I thought you weren't supposed to eat
anything for a couple of hours after
you've had a crown put in
for having this new kind of quick drying
bonding
sounds like a good dentist oh yeah
what's his name
crentist
your dentist's name is crentist
what
is Michael Scott's
greatest fear
um loneliness
maybe women
don't drop the soap don't drop the soap
Michael please
healing
feeling hot hot
there's too many people on this Earth we
need a new plague
[Music]
is he okay
beginning to
you
[Music]
happy birthday to Cave oh get out
Skeleton Man
ny's running over Dwight with his car oh
to be continued
it said specifically that
[Music]
oh God
we're here boss it's starting
open into the hangar there you go
put it in your mouth and just eat it
the man exudes sex
we're moving to Colorado
all of us yep
a bunch of fruits you know Oscar's
allowed to wear sandals but I'm not open
to its shoes is that the how it goes
Meredith your boob is out fine no no
Jan is about to have a baby with a sperm
donor
my goal is preparing for the birth of a
watermelon with Dwight now this baby
will be related to Michael through
delusion
say hello to Danny
me okay you know what try big boobs with
a z let's
password we're in whenever I'm about to
do something I think would an idiot do
that and if they would I do not do that
thing
he knows where it is going the machine
stop yelling at me
remain calm I have trained for this
okay
it's in the window
here we go make a U-turn if possible
[Music]
right up are you okay swim for it
I got you I got you
guys
I got you
come on
all right